let's try the Sicilian open closed okay
I'll kick that guy around maybe oh he is
getting kicked around I'm gonna do it
cuz I don't want D for to happen so I'm
gonna get my Bishop here there might be
okay now basically I just want to target
this pawn mmm go Queen here first
actually why not just D six right away
that's silly
who cares about Queen c7 I do that let's
do this I think a four is a good middle
of that that my queen side is gonna be
peeled open I'm assuming when you
develop here so I stay out of excuse me
so I stay out of my bishop
view he wants to have a clear sight of
this so this is a nice setup to run
forward with Knights connected Queen
Bishop on that main diagonal rook c8 I'm
still waiting for this a for advanced
and you know what might end up happening
this guy becomes a liability
maybe the knight could even with the
eight if the apon exchanges for the
b-pawn then the knight maybe has this
square available I might want to throw a
question to this bishop with age six
okay that move is one that I'm really
not fearing as much as I would this and
if I if I take with the night there is
this push available but maybe I'm quite
alright with that and maybe I'm not okay
let's just restrict this and the other
reason for is I like having this b2 pond
watched over
after something like c4 maybe I could
just do b4 my opponent really needs to
be very cautious of what needs to be
very cautious of moving any pawns that
are on dark squares move pawns
if you move pawns that are on dark
squares you are weakening your dark
squares so this guy being moved huh
weakens d4 and b4 and it allows this
pawn to be hit very soon so there is no
pawn that could be taken if there's a
pawn push does it really matter what
truck I played a c8 I really can't make
out a much of a difference I am going to
however go with this one because I am
seeing possibilities for a structural
change with c4 and I think I want to be
in a spot to respond with B four and
then a five a four and maybe the a file
can open up and short now what do I do
maybe getting my knight here is a good
idea how do I do that I actually have a
leading time here which is rare I can't
move this a pawn
where is the next break and a happen
it's like one more exchange one more
pawn exchanges needed before all these
pieces just come to life now I really
want to make sure that I do what that I
keep the position open let me go here I
think that this is an improvement for
two reasons it's pointing at the King
and getting off of this which is
probably the primary one get after this
C file and now maybe this is available I
think this is the right idea to put
pressure on the ponds that are on dark
squares maybe a nice plan to run forward
with if
if you're in such a position if you're
if you're the side that has that
x-factor bishop this unopposed Bishop
dark square guy all right
morgues more pawn exchanges the better
usually if you have the bishop pair more
diagonals opened up the offer of a queen
exchange mmm I'm okay with that I'm
usually okay with that
definitely usually okay with that
this ponds gonna be under fire soon
isn't he
pawn push pawn push Knights gonna make
use of that square isn't he let me try
this be a bit disruptive to this night
club actually I'm threatened you to trap
it I have a trap up myself oh man I
forgot about that move have that happen
there goes my lights Croatia this was
the first move I was considering you
have to believe me when I say that I was
really I wanted to do that move and then
I got sidetracked I was like if I do
this I was calculating Knight d4 to b5
and I didn't like that the Knights not
taking here hmm get out of there Knight
he's gonna go here and then I have to
worry about d6 right away at least Oh
what up what a bummer
alright maybe I should um look up
what a bug
ah all right looks lovely they are
sitting pretty right here okay now I
think maybe I back up Bishop here
I gotta go quicker
I have to go quicker here that's gonna
do this and I really have to defend
defend defend that's all I'm doing is
defending all right
I just dropped upon oh man this is a
disaster disaster trying to give up my
LightSquared bishop I think I have to
get rid of one of the tricky Knights one
of them King position I think I could
take here on the rook so I get that pawn
back and maybe I don't want this night
to move like after the rook runs away
maybe I just do this if it goes here I
don't want to move my knight I don't
think cuz I'll drop that maybe there's
tricky stuff on f3 I'm having a sense of
that f3 square because look at the
different all the different pieces that
are controlling it convergence squares
if you want to implement that type of a
word into your vocab maybe not a bad one
to run with points of convergence
squares of convergence where two or more
pieces can go to you often see pieces
moving to those squares to just try and
stay harmonious
stay coordinated so now what what's this
rook do where's my opponent - they're
chewing up old precious time right here
if I do this I weaken this square maybe
I do best to just run away with my
knight
right here I work myself into a pin I'm
gonna do it though
cuz I have a convenient way to get out
of it I do this I guard the night and
defend my rook I defend and break the
pin so I think now this bishop posts up
to a really nice square and let's trade
night I think I get that pawn but watch
out for the tricky Knight my bishop is
boxing out the knight now my rook could
finally get active and let's just take
that I don't want to waste time
defending I want to get more active with
my rope I'd like to get this pawn up
here and then there's back rank problems
so maybe I should try that I like my
rook right where it's at because it
keeps this Knight boxed out this is
trouble now give a check first and then
here or the other way around let me give
a check first and then play here making
one threat pawn has to push and then the
king is cut off and that's actually me
my opponent didn't have much time to
sort that out right there ah man
alright good game let me back up I
dropped a pawn and then my opponent not
too long after returned it ah
should this be allowed what I did with
this Bishop and how I was able to lock
down on d3 should this be allowed
um let's see
mmm b5 Bishop b3 their ship c2 Bishop d7
hmm d3 I'm feeling pretty comfortable
because one of the earliest games that I
did in this stream was I was playing the
white side and her excuse me I was
playing the black side my opponent I
forget who my opponent was exactly but I
was emphasizing how getting your F pawn
involved on the white side of an open
Sicilian is usually very important and I
think the same here the same applies
here so this night I think maybe does
well to get out of the way and get this
pawn rolling or maybe it's okay to have
this structure but my suggestion is to
play on the Queen side much sooner and
maybe you can do without the rook move
because unless you're gonna get this
move in successfully and I don't know
that that would really benefit white a
whole lot to get this advance in so
maybe there is an improvement in not
running with rook e1 and instead maybe
Queen e2 or like an immediate look for
an immediate a4 to do something with
this structure maybe Queen e2 is a
better a better one to run with and
notice that maybe this is a case maybe
this is an instance where the Queen is
more limited than this rook and so Queen
d2 still allows for rook e1 or rook d1 I
don't know that there's really a better
Square for the Queen so maybe do that
first retaining some flexibility with
the rook with the follow up being a four
I think I've voiced it during the stream
and it was that when I saw Brooke c1 I
was kind of breathing a little bit more
of a sigh of relief because I thought a
4 was the correct way to improve the
position to really work against
queenside structures since you're not
having this F pond working for you maybe
the the attention should turn towards a
pond break on the queenside and I think
a four is a step in that direction so
that's maybe not a move suggestion but
more like of a a plan suggestion right
getting the queenie to pressure against
these guys coupled with a four i think
is going to be maybe a bit better as it
turns out i am pretty comfortable with
this position right here and with the
queen's often in in the sicilian usually
black is the side that benefits maybe i
could be doing one better with getting
my king a bit closer to defend this pawn
and i certainly should not have allowed
this night a five move so g5 was very
reckless i was getting too too far ahead
of myself i i saw that if i did a five
eventually it'd be night here and then
be five could be made use of but yeah i
shouldn't i should still be doing a five
right now and I guess eventually deal
with the night getting on the b5 square
but all right good game let me close out
here